OUT TO THE STREETS SAYING UNTIL
IT FEELS RIGHT TO LEAVE.
>> Sean: MIKE TOBIN ON THE
GROUND IN MINNEAPOLIS TONIGHT.
AS WE SAID, NEW YORK, CHICAGO,
ATLANTA, OTHER CITIES AND IS
MIKE TOBIN HIGHLIGHTED, HUNDREDS
MOURNING THE DEATH OF GEORGE
FLOYD DURING A MEMORIAL SERVICE
EARLIER TODAY AMONG THE FEATURED
SPEAKERS, TOOK TIME AWAY FROM
THE BUSY JOB TO POLITICIZE THE
EVENTS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE CANNOT USE BIBLES AS A
PROP.
AND FOR THOSE THAT HAVE AGENDAS
THAT ARE NOT ABOUT JUSTICE, THIS
FAMILY WILL NOT LET YOU USE
GEORGE AS A PROP.
TELL THEM ABOUT MAKING AMERICA
GREAT.
GREAT FOR WHO AND GREAT WHEN?
WE ARE GOING TO MAKE AMERICA
GREAT FOR EVERYBODY FOR THE
FIRST TIME.
>> Sean: PERHAPS AL SHARPTON
MISSED THE PRESIDENT’S COMMENTS,
MISSED HIS EARLY DEMAND FOR
IMMEDIATE JUSTICE AND EXPEDITED
AN INVESTIGATION, DOJ BROUGHT IN
BY THE PRESIDENT, AND THE CIVIL
RIGHTS DIVISION TO WORK WITH
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITIES WHO WERE FIRED IN
RECORD TIME, ALL FOUR OFFICERS
HAVE NOW BEEN CHARGED, SERIOUS
CHARGES, AND WE BELIEVE THAT
JUSTICE WILL BE SERVED.
BUT NOW YOU’VE GOT FEAR,
DIVISION, HATRED, EVERYTHING IS
IN TRUMP’S NAME.
AND HIS HOME CITY, AL SHARPTON
IS UNDER ATTACK.
LAST NIGHT IN THE CITY OF
NEW YORK, TWO OFFICERS WERE
SHOT, ANOTHER STABBED RIGHT IN
THE NECK.
THEY WERE PATROLLING THE STREETS
OF BROOKLYN FOR LOOTERS BUT NOW
PROBING THE PERPETRATORS
POSSIBLE LINKS TO TERRORISTS.
AFTER A WEEK OF VIOLENCE, POLICE
HAVE BEEN SHOT, RUN OVER BY
CARS, BEATEN BY MOBS, HIT IN THE
HEAD WITH BRICKS, FROZEN WATER
BOTTLES AND OTHER PROJECTILES.
SEVERAL MEMBERS OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT HAVE DIED, SOME
FIGHTING FOR THEIR LIVES AND
LIFE SUPPORT WITH
LIFE-THREATENING INJURIES AS WE
SPEAK THEM UP AT THE CHAOS
CONTINUES.
JUST LAST NIGHT, SURVEILLANCE
VIDEO CAPTURING LOOTERS RAVAGING
A DRONE STORE IN MANHATTAN, JUST
1 OF HUNDREDS OF BUSINESSES THAT
WERE LOOTED, VANDALIZED, OR SET
ABLAZE OVER THE PAST WEEK.
YOU HAVE THE POLITICS OF THIS,
THE SO-CALLED SOLUTION NOW TO
ALL THE VIOLENCE AND ALL THE
ANARCHY AND ALL THE LAWLESSNESS
AND LOOTING AND ARSON AND
VIOLENCE IS LET’S GET RID OF THE
POLICE ALTOGETHER BECAUSE THAT
IS APPARENTLY NOW THEIR NEW
BATTLE CRY.
THEY WANT TO ABOLISH POLICE
OFFICERS.
HILLARY CLINTON’S FORMER
SPOKESPERSON TWEETING "DEFUND
THE POLICE."
AND YOU HAVE THE HOLLYWOOD
WHO’S WHO LIST, JOHN LEGEND,
JANE FONDA, MANY OTHER
CELEBRITIES SIGNING AN OPEN
LETTER DEMANDING THAT WE DEFUND
THE POLICE.
TODAY, THE MAYOR OF LOS ANGELES,
THE CITY COUNCIL VOWING TO CUT
OVER $100 MILLION FROM THE
L.A.P.D. BUDGET IN NEW YORK, AT
LEAST 40 CITY COUNCIL CANDIDATES
NOW CALLING FOR A BILLION-DOLLAR
CUT TO THE NYPD IN MINNEAPOLIS
CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS ARE
ACTUALLY VOWING TO DISMANTLE THE
ENTIRE POLICE DEPARTMENT.
AND MEANWHILE, BLACK LIVES
MATTER AS WE TOLD YOU LAST NIGHT
WANT TO PUSH ALL POLICE OUT OF
THE INNER, REPLACE THEM WITH
THEIR OWN ARMED MILITIA.
IN THE SAME GROUP YOU MIGHT
RECALL THAT WAS CHANTING WHAT DO
WE WANT?
DEAD COPS, PIGS IN A BLANKET,
FRY THEM LIKE THEY CAN.
THIS GROUP WANTS ARM TO SELF
POLICING?
SERIOUSLY?
WITHOUT A DOUBT, DEMOCRATS SEEM
TO BE EMBRACING THIS ANARCHY.
TODAY, THE PRESIDENT RESPONDED
AND TWEETED "THE NEW THEME IS
DEFUND THE POLICE.
REMEMBER THAT WHEN YOU DON’T
WANT CRIME ESPECIALLY AGAINST
YOU AND YOUR FAMILY.
THIS IS WHAT SLEEPY JOE BIDEN IS
BEING DRAGGED BY THE SOCIALISTS.
THE COMPLETE OPPOSITE, MORE
MONEY FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT.
SENATOR TOM COTTON OFFERED AN
OP-ED IN "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
CALLING FOR U.S. TROOPS TO BE
UTILIZED TO RESTORE ORDER.
IN THE PRESIDENT SAYING HE
DOESN’T THINK THAT WILL BE
NECESSARY, BUT ALSO BRINGS UP
THE ISSUE OF WHY THESE CITIES
AND MAYORS AND GOVERNORS ARE
SAYING TO THE PRESIDENT KNOW, WE
DON’T WANT NATIONAL GUARD HELP.
THEY HAVE TO ASK FOR IT.
AND OTHERWISE, THE PRESIDENT
WOULD HAVE TO INVOKE A
INSURRECTION ACT WHICH I DON’T
THINK IS NECESSARY AND WE SHOULD
NOT HAVE TO DO.
THEY SHOULD BE TAKING CONTROL OF
THEIR OWN STATES AND CITIES.
THIS HAS CAUSED AN INTERNAL
MELTDOWN, THE NEW YORK TOILET
PAPER TIMES, SOME WERE
APPARENTLY APOPLECTIC THAT THE
TIMES PUBLISHED A VIEWPOINT
DIFFERENT THAN THEIR OWN LIBERAL
VIEW.
THE STAFF OF THE TIMES CLAIMED
THE WORDS IN THE OP-ED PUT
MINORITY STAFF MEMBERS IN DANGER
AND THE TOILET PAPER TIMES
ULTIMATELY APOLOGIZING FOR
PUBLISHING THE OP-ED.
TODAY IN A VERY KIND GESTURE,
COTTON TWEETED "HOW IS EVERYONE
AT "THE NEW YORK TIMES" DOING
TONIGHT?
I CAN REPORT TONIGHT THAT
THEY’RE NOT DOING WELL BECAUSE
TWO WEEKS AGO, THE LEFT WAS
DEMANDING THAT POLICE OFFICERS
ARREST ANYONE NOT PROPERLY
SOCIALLY DISTANCING, AND NOW IT
IS CLEAR THEY WANT TO GET RID OF
ALL COPS ALTOGETHER AND IT IS
COMING AT A TIME WHEN
LAW ENFORCEMENT IS NOW
INVESTIGATING WHETHER OR NOT
ANTIFA IS ORGANIZING THE VIOLENT
ELEMENTS IN THIS WEEK’S
PROTESTS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THERE ARE EXTREMIST AGITATORS
WHO ARE HIJACKING THE PROTESTS
TO PURSUE THEIR OWN SEPARATE AND
VIOLENT AGENDA.
WE HAVE EVIDENCE THAT ANTIFA AND
OTHER SIMILAR EXTREMIST GROUPS
AS WELL AS ACTORS OF A VARIETY
OF DIFFERENT POLITICAL
PERSUASIONS HAVE BEEN INVOLVED
IN INSTIGATING AND PARTICIPATING
IN THE VIOLENT ACTIVITY, AND WE
ARE ALSO SEEING FOREIGN ACTORS
PLAYING BOTH SIDES TO EXACERBATE
THE VIOLENCE.
>> Sean: THE AG IS RIGHT.
SO WHAT ABOUT THIS GROUP, WHO
ARE THESE PEOPLE AND ARE THEY
REALLY ORGANIZING VIOLENCE ALL
ACROSS THE U.S.?
WE BEGAN A HAND OF THE
INVESTIGATION.
ANTIFA EXPOSED BECAUSE OVER THE
PAST WEEK, SOME HAVE BEEN
BLAMING ANTIFA.
TRACE GALLAGHER REPORTING ABOUT
PILES OF BRICKS THAT ARE STAGED
SHOWING UP AT PROTEST SITES ALL
ACROSS THE COUNTRY, ALSO
WITNESSED SCENES OF ALLEGED
ANTI-FOR MEMBERS DRESSED IN ALL
BLACK WEARING MASKS AND HELMETS
ALL WHILE BREAKING INTO STORES,
SMASHING WINDOWS, SPRAY PAINTING
BUILDINGS AND ASSAULTING THE
POLICE.
IN TEXAS, HAS BEEN ACCUSED OF
COORDINATING THE LOOTING OF A
LOCAL TARGET AND ACCORDING TO A
LENGTHY UNDERCOVER INVESTIGATION
FROM PROJECT VERITAS, JAMES